we're live
is it working hey how's it going
everyone how are you all doing
uh it's just me today silas is making a
video currently so he's
uh hellbent on getting that release for
you guys but i figured i would do a
reaction
uh coming here from the gaming channel
on hogwarts legacy official reveal
trailer i know nothing about this game i
didn't know it was even coming out i
didn't know anything about it
um but i'm excited to check out the
trailer and we'll definitely be playing
it lots
on this channel because well it pertains
to harry potter of course so
let's get into it and see what it's all
about
magic both beautiful and powerful
binds together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
[Music]
now it is time to add your own story to
these hallowed halls
and quite possibly shape the future
of the wizarding world
late 1800s wow every portrait every
stone
in this castle tells the story
of witches and wizards who came before
so this is a prequel here you will meet
lifelong friends
and grow into your own magical abilities
in the classrooms of the world's most
talented professors
and while your journey begins it holds
brewing potions taming fantastic beasts
and mastery spells
there is a larger world beyond these
walls
oh wow well filled with dangers you
can't yet
imagine an ancient knowledge
long gone from this world
what was that like the room of
requirements the mysterious talent you
possess
may be the key to unlocking this dormant
power
your potential
is limitless
but what form will it take
[Music]
the journey ahead will reveal
what you stand for
the services you make now
will define the legacy of hogwarts
is this an open world game is this an
open world hogwarts
what let me see this
let me see this this is an open world
game
i think it is experienced the new story
set at hogwarts in the 1800s
which is very cool we get prequels i
wonder how far into
the timeline it goes uh your character
is a student who holds the key to
an ancient secret that threatens to tear
the wizarding world apart
make allies battle dark wizards and
decide the
so you can't be a dark wizard battle
dark wizards and decide for the fate of
the wizarding world
this seems very fun so uh we're
definitely
playing this 100 is this something you
guys would like to see on the channel i
think
i think it'd be fun i mean i know it
pertains to the gaming channel but i
figure
i mean there's probably tons of
canon lore that we can learn from this
so it'll be fun to speculate and have
fun and
and uh go through different
levels and it's a prequel so really all
the things are going to be
new to us or newer maybe we'll learn
the true origins and see you know tom
riddle
if it goes that far if it goes maybe 100
or so years later
and we can see
these hallowed walls
and quite possibly shape the future
this is like an old republic harry
potter it's like an old republic star
wars harry potter
every corridor i think it's gonna be
great
uh i wish silas was here to react to it
too but silas i know you're making that
video so make sure you guys go check it
out
um that's all just wanted to see this
with you guys live and
i hope you're all having a great day uh
you're yeah you'd be down for the i'm
reading the chat right now you'd be down
for
live streams of this i think it would be
very fun
hey parth hey sabrina how are you all
doing hope you're having a great day
all right well um that's it for me i
just wanted to check this out with you
all
and uh does it say when it comes out i
guess when
playstation comes out perhaps either way
as soon as it comes out
you can expect daily uploads uh lore
videos explanations
and then uh live streams with this so
actually